gotham city a cauldron of crime and  corruption about to boil over i'm trying  to save the city so am i i just get paid  for it better than you do a new  nightmare whispers from the edges of  sanity this is  [Music]  they remember you invited me a criminal  mastermind makes a play for total  control there is a terrible corruption  at the heart of the gotham city police  department and it goes by the name  batman  and an agent of chaos makes her deadly  debut  i think i used to be a doctor hang on to  your headphones and tune in for 10  all-new explosive episodes stream every  episode of dc's batman the audio  adventures season 2 on hbo max starting  october 7th and don't miss the 7 issue  batman the audio adventures comic book  series by the writer of the  award-winning batman the audio  adventures podcast get it at a comic  shop near you or read it digitally with  a subscription to dc universe infinite  dc universe infinite dot com